we are going to begin on Capitol Hill
with the Frantic efforts to raise
America's borrowing limit to make sure
we can keep paying America's bills
paying seniors paying the military
paying our creditors all of it lawmakers
on both sides of the aisle they are
under intense pressure to accept the
deal as it is it was struck by President
Biden and house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
but with a big vote in the house
expected later today more than two dozen
are already vowing to reject the
agreement this could be very bad Nicole
Killian is on Capitol Hill for us Nicole
good morning it's never happened before
are there enough votes to get this thing
passed and raise the debt ceiling well
good morning to you Tony we will see
House Republicans met behind closed
doors for about two hours last night to
try to rally support for this bill GOP
leaders are projecting confidence but
it's still not clear if the votes are
there
all those in favor signify by saying aye
aye today the debt deal is Bound for the
house floor after clearing the powerful
rules committee Tuesday night by one
vote what do the 13 of us owe the rest
of Congress
we we owe them an honest Shake Kentucky
Congressman Thomas Massey helped push
the measure over the edge after it
failed to get unanimous support from
panel Republicans like chip Roy is it
worth blowing up this deal when you have
that default deadline less than a week
from now default is off the table it'll
be the president United States that
would choose the default at least 20
Republicans say they'll vote no on a
final bill it would lift the debt limit
past the 2024 election and according to
new projections by the Congressional
budget office cut spending by 1.5
trillion dollars over a decade
what do you say to your fellow
Republicans who are confirmed no keep
walking backwards
are they Expendable are you looking to
flip them
the deal brokered between speaker
McCarthy and President Biden has some
hard-line conservatives calling for the
speaker's alster do you think he should
lose his job you know I think it's
necessary because he's
catastrophically failed in this
negotiation it's also tough to swallow
for some Progressive Democrats concerned
about tougher work requirements and
other carve outs to have the the
president solely negotiating with
Republicans itself
um I don't think it was a really good
look we want to make sure there's no
default so that's priority number one
but we also need to hold our ground and
stand up for the most vulnerable
Americans minority leader Hakeem Jeffrey
has told me he's having discussions with
his members and this morning White House
negotiators and top eight will brief
house Democrats on the deal here at the
Capitol Nate
Nicole we appreciate your diligent work
indirect questions on this topic because
time is of the essence thank you